estamos en el momento perfecto para
hacer un nuevo ejercicio que tenga que
ver con ecuaciones diferenciales de
primer orden pero que cumplan la
propiedad de que sean homogéneas con
este ejercicio lo que yo quiero hacer es
que ustedes les quede mucho más claro la
idea de un cambio de variable me voy a
tomar un ejercicio muy parecido al
ejercicio anterior pero un poco más
difícil en esta ocasión voy a tomar la
derivada de ley con respecto a x igual a
una función que tenga que ver con ye y
con x y esta función va a ser x cuadrada
más 3 que cuadrada y esto lo voy a
dividir entre 2 veces x
la vez pasada lo que analizábamos era la
idea de hacer un cambio de variable y de
hecho nosotros tomábamos el cambio de
variable entre x y con esto lográbamos
hacer una separación de variables así
que lo que se me ocurre es multiplicar
esta ecuación por 1 pero por un 1
tramposo y una tramposa va a ser 1 / x
cuadrada / 1 / x cuadrada así bien que
si multiplicamos la parte de arriba por
1 / x cuadrada pues x cuadrada entre x
cuadrada en meta 1 y 3 y cuadrada entre
x cuadrada pues me da tres veces y
cuadrada entre x cuadrado y en la parte
de abajo pues tenemos un 2 y una x que
se puede ir con una x de acá abajo
entonces me va a quedar que entre x y en
este momento voy a escribir esta
expresión de una manera que me va a
dejar ver mucho más nítidamente que es
lo que está pasando pues me cambio de
variable lo voy a escribir como 13 que
multiplica a entre x elevado al cuadrado
y esto sobre 2 que multiplica allí entre
x de esta manera ya se ve mucho más
claro quién va a ser mi cambio de
variable y de hecho que voy a hacer le
voy a llamar a mi cambio de variable v y
esta v va a ser y entre x o dicho de
otra manera y es igual a x por ver esto
lo hacía porque yo ya puedo derivar a ye
con respecto a x cosa que hice en el
vídeo pasado y como era una
multiplicación de funciones pues de
aunque deriva el primero x que es 1 y
multiplicarlo por ver ya esto sumarle la
derivada de b y multiplicarlo por x es
decir x que multiplica la derivada de b
con respecto a x y ahora que ya tenemos
nuestro cambio de variable y además
tenemos la derivada de jake con respecto
a x entonces ya podemos sustituir es
nuestro siguiente paso entonces si yo
pongo la derivada de jay con respecto a
x pues esto era p más x por b prima ojo
estoy pudiendo ver prima para no cargar
todo el tiempo con la derivada de b con
respecto a x es mucho más fácil así y
del otro lado que tengo pues uno más 3 b
cuadrada porque ya estoy usando mi
cambio de variable aquí era y en tres
elevado al cuadrado pues es p cuadrada
y dividido entre dos o sea dos porque
entre x usando otra vez me cambio de
variable y es en este momento cuando me
voy a quitar la capa de ecuaciones
diferenciales y ahora me voy a poner la
capa de álgebra para pasar esto a
variables separables lo primero que voy
a hacer es multiplicar todo de un lado y
de otro por 2 b
entonces me va a quedar 2 b cuadrada +
2x por b por b prima y esto va a ser
igual a 13 b cuadrada es decir estoy
pasando al 2 t del otro lado
multiplicando y ahora lo que se me
ocurre es bueno primero aquí puedo
reducir un poco puedo poner 2x b por b
prima y fíjense que aquí tengo 2 de
cuadrada y 3 b cuadrada entonces los
puedo restar me va a quedar solamente de
cuadrada
ya tengo una ecuación mucho más sencilla
ahora lo que voy a hacer es dividir todo
entre 1 + b cuadrado así va a ser mucho
más fácil que tenga las veces de un lado
y después las x del otro entonces
obtenemos 2x por 20 por ver prima entre
1 + de cuadrada y del otro lado pues uno
más de cuadrada entre 1 + b cuadrada es
1 ahora que queda del lado izquierdo de
nuestra ecuación solamente lo que tenga
que ver con b y del lado derecho
solamente lo que tengan que ver con x es
decir me va a quedar 2 b y aquí en lugar
de mi prima ahora sí voy a cambiar a la
derivada de b con respecto a x esto es
porque el diferencial de x ahorita
también me voy a deshacer de él y esto
lo divide 1 + b cuadrado mientras que
del lado derecho voy a pasar la x
dividiendo es decir me va a quedar 1 / x
bien ahora yo escribí mi prima como la
derivada de b con respecto a x porque el
de x lo voy a pasar del otro lado para
que podamos integrar ahora sí tanto de
un lado como de otro ahora pongamos los
morados para pasar a la zona de
integración
voy a integrar pues 2 p entre 1 más de
cuadrada de b ojo aquí está el debe y
del otro lado pues tengo uno entre xy
voy a pasar el de x del otro lado y pues
integremos integremos aquí integremos
acá y que voy a obtener bueno
cuál es la integral de 2 p entre 1 más
cuadrada de b
lo primero que quiero que vean es que la
derivada de 1 b cuadrada está acá arriba
estás b si yo digo esto pues la derivada
de uno es cero y la derivada de b
cuadrada es 2 b y cuando nosotros
aprendimos a integrar no sé si ustedes
se acuerdan que cuando yo tenían las
derivadas de una función entre esa
función pues tenía que ver con el
logaritmo natural de esa función del
valor absoluto de esa función entonces
pues vamos a escribirlo aquí esto va a
ser el logaritmo natural de uno más b al
cuadrado cuando era absoluto pero pues
esto siempre es positivo no uno más de
cuadrada pues es positivo entonces no es
necesario que le pongamos el valor
absoluto
es el logaritmo natural de 1 + b
cuadrado si hoy antes de incrédulos
ustedes lo pueden probar haciendo un
cambio de variable podrían decir que es
igual a 1 + b cuadrada y pues verán que
su derivada es 2p y entonces al final es
va a quedar el logaritmo natural de 1 +
b cuadrado bien y pues del otro lado yo
tengo que es 1 / x a cuál es su integral
de 1 / x pues es una cosa muy parecida
se dan cuenta la integral de 1 / x es ni
más ni menos que el logaritmo natural
del valor absoluto de x entonces lo voy
a escribir logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto de x más una constante pero en
esta ocasión voy a escribir mi constante
como más me convenga voy a escribir me
en constante como el logaritmo natural
de el valor absoluto de una constante
pues el logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto de una constante es una
constante entonces puesto puedo hacer al
final es una constante no hay ningún
problema porque hago esto pues porque yo
puedo escribir el logaritmo natural de
uno más b al cuadrado es igual a y aquí
hay una suma de logaritmos
y por las propiedades de los logaritmos
esto es lo mismo que la multiplicación
de lo que está dentro de los valores
absolutos es decir el logaritmo natural
de una constante por x en valor absoluto
y ahora si tengo un logaritmo acá tengo
un logaritmo ya pues los puedo cancelar
y me va a quedar simplemente que uno más
b cuadrada es igual a una constante por
x para no hacer las cosas tremendamente
complicadas fue por eso que puse el
logaritmo natural de una constante y
ahora sí voy a sustituir a be cuadrada
pero b cuadrada era entre x elevado al
cuadrado porque b era y entre x y ahora
si obtengo que uno más entre x elevada
al cuadrado es igual a una constante por
x y si yo distribuyó mi cuadrado pues
esto es ya cuadrado entre x cuadrada y
ahora voy a multiplicar todo por x
cuadrada para poder despejar allí
cuadrada es decir me va a quedar x
cuadrada más y cuadrada igual hace por x
kubica porque x x x cuadrada puestas x
cúbica y ahora pasemos el otro lado el
cx cúbica pues para que se vista esto
como de una curva entonces me va a
quedar x cuadrada malla cuadrada menos x
cúbica igual a cero
esto es una función a una correa pero lo
importante es que es la solución de esta
ecuación diferencial que noten de una
vez que era de primer orden y voy a
tratar de una vez antes de que se nos
escape nuestra solución nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo que de hecho en el
siguiente vídeo lo que quiero ver es
ecuaciones diferenciales pero con un
orden superior es decir nos vamos a ir
un poco más elevados cuídense mucho